from a dentist's nightmare to a bunch of
friends erotically obsessed with car
crashes there have been a lot of movies
which push the boundaries of the love
scene
according to University College London
researchers there's an old folk tale
about women with vagina dentata or a
second set of very sharp teeth down
below it's not a real medical condition
and probably stems from Men's fear and
lack of understanding of female
sexuality going back hundreds of years
the 2007 low-budget horror comedy teeth
took this old Legend and the sexual
politics that inspired it as the basis
for its story creating an allegory about
adolescence and the physical changes
that it brings Jess weixler's Dawn
hasn't explored her sexuality much and
is very involved in her High School's
Chastity Club but that changes when she
meets hail appleman's Toby things are
going all right at first until he
suddenly turns impatient and violent
turning a love scene into a sickening
assault scene but Dawn puts a swift into
it thanks to her previously undiscovered
physical Quirk effectively severing Toby
from his manhood
the room starring written by and
directed by Tommy Wiseau is a cult
classic and widely considered among the
worst movies ever made amid the other
atrocities in this movie is a pair of
love scenes between with those Johnny
and his future wife Lisa played by Julia
Danielle well it's really just one love
scene repeated twice feeling like it's
out of one of cinemax's low budget
erotica from the 80s and 90s it was
great but three is a crowd
I get it you guys want to be alone the
scene is shot through Gauzy white
curtains and then a rainy window the odd
foreplay is lit by candles and abrasive
neon light with Johnny positively
obsessed with a single red rose plucking
off each petal and throwing them at Lisa
but when we finally reach the big moment
the couple is misaligned seemingly
unable to understand what's supposed to
happen and then it just keeps going and
going and going David cronenberg's films
are always delightfully provocative
transgressive and bewildering he's
famous for his body horror films and
psychological thrillers in 1996 he wrote
and directed crash an NC-17 rated
adaptation of the dark and edgy novel of
the same name by JG Ballard this movie
is all about obscure fetishistic sex
James Spader plays James Ballard who
after getting into a near-fatal car
accident finds a group of people who
derive pleasure from vehicular mishaps
they channel the fear anxiety City and
adrenaline rush into erotic energy which
means that several of crash's intimate
scenes are also violent car wrecks and
as you know car crashes cause injuries
and for Rosanna Arquette's Gabrielle
it's a big wound on her leg Spader's
character then treats it as he would any
other naturally occurring bodily orifice
on a partner
Seth Rogen's done a lot of cringy sex
scenes but Judd Apatow's 2007 Coming of
Age comedy may just take the cake love
scenes can trigger a lot of unexpected
or unintended reactions laughter disgust
Confusion And even annoyance but Apatow
goes for the whole pot in Knocked Up in
the film Rogan's bin is an immature and
irresponsible guy forced to quickly
become an adult when Catherine Heigl's
Allison learns she's pregnant from their
one night stand Alison decides to carry
the child to term and requests that Ben
come back into her life as a partner
they bicker throughout the movie
particularly over whiny and lazy Ben's
inability and unwillingness to change
but they still decide to make a go of a
more permanent romantic situation you'd
think the initial clumsy drunk
lovemaking scene between the two of them
setting the drama in motion is the most
uncomfortable one in the film but no
after they're back together Ben and
Allison find themselves in the middle of
another baby-making act except Alison is
already very far into her pregnancy
rather than be in the moment in any way
Ben obsesses over a myth that's
dispelled on day one of Junior High
health class it all I see is our baby
today poked in the face we are not even
close
[Music]